We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP.
我们得到加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。哔。哔。哔。
Saroos Farovar is on a mission. He's trying to get a case of beer called West Flatern. West Flatern. I'm not Dutch, so I'm not 100% sure. But I think it's West Flatern. It's not easy to get, but apparently it's worth it. Oh, yes. If you're a beer nerd or have a friend
萨鲁什·法罗瓦尔（Saroos Farovar）肩负着一项使命。他正试图买到一箱名为西弗leteren（Westvleteren）的啤酒。西弗勒特伦。我不是荷兰人，所以我不是百分之百确定。但我认为是西弗勒特伦。这并不容易买到，但显然这是值得的。哦，是的。如果你是一个啤酒迷，或者有一个朋友
who's a beer nerd, you've probably heard of Belgian beers. Belgians take their beer very seriously. They're about 200 breweries in a country about twice the size of the Bay Area. We're on from. Now amongst these Belgian breweries and Belgian ails, there's a very specific subtype, trappist beers. Anyone who knows anything about beer will probably start to get glassy-eyed and have a warm, delicious feeling whenever they talk about
他是一个啤酒迷，你可能听说过比利时啤酒。比利时人对他们的啤酒非常认真。在面积约为旧金山湾区两倍的国家里，大约有200家酿酒厂。我们在……现在，在这些比利时啤酒厂和比利时艾尔啤酒中，有一个非常具体的子类型，即修道院啤酒（Trappist beers）。任何懂啤酒的人，每当谈到
them, myself included. Sentences will be punctuated with superlatives and exclamations. Now I'm a person just like you, but I don't actually drink beer, so off the takes of the the sources word for it. Or the word of one of the many beer reviewers on YouTube. It's a beautiful thing. It's all dried fruit. It's boozy. It's earthy.
它们时，大概都会双眼放光，心里涌起一股温暖、美妙的感觉，包括我在内。句子里会充满最高级和惊叹词。现在我是一个和你一样的人，但我其实不喝啤酒，所以只能听信消息来源的话。或者听听 YouTube 上众多啤酒评论员之一的话。这太美妙了。全是干果味。有酒香。有泥土气息。
It looks amazing. It's something that was woody and tannic about it. It's so many flavors going on in there. Yes, and I think we all know what you're going to get there. This isn't a place. I can't, I mean I can't give anything less. That's something else. The flavour just keeps on going and going and going. My tongue is tingling. Yeah, it's...
它看起来棒极了。它带有一种木质和单宁的味道。里面有太多的风味。是的，我想我们都知道你在那里能得到什么。这不是一个地方。我不能，我的意思是，我不能给出低于这个的评价。那是别的东西。风味连绵不绝。我的舌头在发麻。是的，它是……
Wow. Here's what you need to know about trapeze beers. First, they're amazing. Second, they're made by trapeze monks. These monks trace their roots to a monastery in 17th century France and have since spread out to all over the world. The main concept behind the trappist lifestyle is that the Abbi should be economically self-sufficient. In other words, the monks should make something and sell it to the public as a way to fund
哇。关于修道院啤酒，你需要知道以下几点。首先，它们棒极了。其次，它们是由修道院修士酿造的。这些修士的根源可以追溯到 17 世纪法国的一个修道院，此后传遍了世界各地。修道院生活方式背后的主要理念是修道院应该在经济上自给自足。换句话说，修士们应该制作一些东西并将其出售给公众，以此来资助
the operations of the Abbi itself. Some make cheese, some make spirits, and there's even one in Germany that makes lentil soup. But none of the trappist products are nearly anywhere as famous as the beer. Only seven beer-making trappist Abbey's exist. Sixer in Belgium, and one is in the Netherlands. The most widely available trappist beer is Chime. You can get it in a lot of U.S. specialty grocery stores and some bars too. They make over 3 million gallons of this stuff a year. By comparison, West Bladerin makes less than 4% of that volume annually.
修道院本身的运营。有些制作奶酪，有些制作烈酒，甚至德国还有一家制作扁豆汤。但没有一种修道院产品的名气能接近啤酒。现存的酿造修道院啤酒的修道院只有七家。六家在比利时，一家在荷兰。最容易买到的修道院啤酒是智美（Chimay）。你可以在许多美国特色杂货店和一些酒吧买到它。他们每年生产超过 300 万加仑这种酒。相比之下，西弗勒特伦每年的产量还不到那个数字的 4%。
But West Bladerin with its plain brown bottle, no label, and the only writing is on the cap. It's super cool. It's one of the rarest and many say. It's the best beer in the world. But here's the thing about West Bladerin. you can't go there and have as much beer as you want. You can't even have it shipped from the Abbey.
但西弗勒特伦用着朴素的棕色瓶子，没有标签，唯一的文字写在瓶盖上。这太酷了。它是最稀有的啤酒之一，许多人说它是世界上最好的啤酒。但关于西弗勒特伦，情况是这样的：你不能去那里随心所欲地喝个够。你甚至不能让修道院把它运过来。
If you want to buy beer to take with you, you have to look up the beer reservation phone number on the Abbey's website. Then you call this certain phone number during certain hours on certain days. As the monks themselves warn on the site, Please take into account that you may often get a busy signal when you call to make a reservation. hours on certain days, as the monks themselves warn on the site. reservations. That means it's a matter of having a lot of patience as well as a lot of luck. And here's what you need to understand about me. I am totally game for this. I love being challenged as a food consumer. In fact, there's a burger place in Connecticut that claims to have invented the hamburger in America. And, you know, true to their
如果你想买啤酒带走，你必须在修道院的网站上查找啤酒预订电话号码。然后你在某些日子的某些时间拨打这个特定的电话号码。正如修士们自己在网站上警告的那样：“请注意，当你打电话进行预订时，你经常可能会遇到占线信号。”在某些日子的某些小时，正如修士们自己在网站上警告的那样。预订。这意味着这既需要极大的耐心，也需要极大的运气。关于我，你需要了解的是：我完全愿意接受这个挑战。我喜欢作为一名食品消费者受到挑战。事实上，康涅狄格州有一家汉堡店声称自己发明了美国的汉堡。而且，你知道，忠于他们的
century-old rules, they refuse to serve burgers with ketchup or mustard. And they only serve it on toast. I love that. I mean, if they told me that I had to do 50 jumping jacks and run around the block, and then I could get a burger, I would totally do that too. BEEP. Anyway, back to what's later.
几个世纪前的规则，他们拒绝提供加番茄酱或芥末的汉堡。而且他们只用烤面包来供应。我喜欢这样。我的意思是，如果他们告诉我必须做 50 个开合跳并绕着街区跑一圈，然后才能得到一个汉堡，我也会完全照做。哔。无论如何，回到西弗勒特伦。
BEEP. BEEP. Later. Good day, bonjour, hello. You went for a bonnum met de biebrecope van de syncixis md. If you're lucky enough to talk to a monk, and yes, you do talk to a monk, to take your reservation, you have to give your license plate number and be available to come pick up your crate during the appointed time that weekend. You're limited to one crate per person, per car, maximum to per car. And you can't buy more than one crate during a 60 day period.
哔。哔。稍后。日安，您好，你好。如果你足够幸运能跟一个修士对话——是的，你确实是跟一个修士对话——来完成预订，你必须提供你的车牌号，并确保能在那个周末的指定时间去提取你的木箱。每人每车限购一箱，每车最多两箱。并且你在 60 天内不能购买超过一箱。
Oh, and you agree not to resell the beer as well. For information, please see our website, www. You got that. There is a list of several seemingly arbitrary hoops that you have to jump through if you want to buy this beer. This sort of thing is not unheard of.
哦，你还得同意不转售这款啤酒。有关信息，请访问我们的网站 www。你懂的。如果你想买这种啤酒，你必须跳过几个看似武断的圈套。这种事并不是闻所未闻。
Velvet ropes and random reward have long been imposed to create artificial scarcity and to heighten demand. But the mainstream trend today seems to be more geared towards greater access and accommodation for customers. The new idea is that everything is available at all times no matter where you live. This is the digital age, but clearly this is not the case for the West lettering trappists. They're trying to make it as difficult as possible. No, no, no, no, no, they don't make it difficult. You make it difficult. Too much people want this beer. This is Jeff Von Dynstein. He's the author of a book called Trappist, the Seven Heavenly Beers. And he's even a brewer himself.
天鹅绒绳索和随机奖励长期以来一直被用来制造人为的稀缺性并推高需求。但当今的主流趋势似乎更多地转向为客户提供更大的便利和无障碍服务。新的理念是，无论你住在哪里，一切都可以随时随地买到。这是数字时代，但对于西弗勒特伦的修士们来说，显然情况并非如此。他们正试图让它变得尽可能困难。不，不，不，不，不，他们没有让它变得困难。是你让它变得困难的。太多人想要这款啤酒了。这是杰夫·范·戴恩斯坦（Jeff Van Dyck）。他是《修道院：七款天堂啤酒》一书的作者。他自己甚至也是一名酿酒师。
Until ten years ago, you could go to the Abbey, except on Sunday, because then they don't work. And except on Friday, because Friday they don't work, because they don't eat Friday. But Saturday they were open, so you went there and without problems you could buy beer, not as much as you want, but normally three crates or two crates, so it was always possible. But then the Americans, it's all your fault. I'm sorry, now the Americans set with flateness the best beer of the world. Because English is a word language, not only in the US, England, but also Scandinavian countries.
直到十年前，你都可以去修道院，除了星期天，因为他们那天不工作。除了星期五，因为星期五他们不工作，因为他们星期五不吃东西。但星期六他们开门，所以你去了那里，毫无问题地就能买到啤酒，虽然不是你想要多少就能买多少，但通常是三箱或两箱，所以一直都是可行的。但后来，美国人，这都是你们的错。对不起，现在美国人把西弗勒特伦奉为世界上最好的啤酒。因为英语是一门世界语言，不仅在美国、英国，还有斯堪的纳维亚国家。
So everywhere where they speak or understand English, they could read beer advocate and all those websites. And suddenly the demand of this beer was 10 times bigger. And that's a problem. It's not their problem. They brew now the same amount as they did before. Keep in mind, this was basically the first thing that Jeff said to me when I sat down with him.
所以在所有说英语或懂英语的地方，他们都可以阅读 Beer Advocate 和所有这些网站。突然之间，这款啤酒的需求量增加了 10 倍。这是一个问题。但这并非他们的问题。他们现在的酿酒量和以前一样多。请记住，这基本上是杰夫和我坐下来时说的第一句话。
And I sort of felt guilty, to be honest, because he was right. I'd heard about this beer for years. And now that I was living within striking distance just over the border in Germany, there was no way I was going to pass it up. Just an older guy with a full bushy, gray beard. And he seems to know just about everything about beer. And having written about the trappest monks, he was the closest that I was going to get to an actual monk. But Jeff as sort of trappist monk by proxy outlined the main reason for putting up
老实说，我有点感到内疚，因为他是对的。我听说这款啤酒已经好几年了。现在我就住在德国边境对面、唾手可得的地方，我绝不可能错过它。他只是一个留着浓密灰白胡须的老年人。他似乎对啤酒无所不知。由于写过关于修道院修士的文章，他是我能找到的最接近真正修士的人。但是杰夫作为某种代理修道院修士，概述了设置
these obstacles to getting West Flatern. They decided we brewed the same amount as the last 40, 50 years and they have enough with that. So why must they brew more? Because you want. No. And they live between the walls of the rabbi, so for them it's not a problem.
购买西弗勒特伦障碍的主要原因。他们决定我们酿造的量和过去 40、50 年一样多，他们觉得这就够了。那他们为什么还要酿造更多？因为你想要。不。而且他们生活在修道院的墙内，所以对他们来说这不是问题。
So with that in mind, and after spending about 90 minutes at Jeff's brewery, de Glazer Torren, and of course we bought some bottles to take with us, my three friends and I headed out to visit the famed amunks of West Flaterin. Now as we mentioned earlier, you have to order ahead if you want to buy a case of beer. Unfortunately, Ceruse didn't have any luck ordering crates, but he knew he could at least sample someone he got there.
带着这个想法，在杰夫的啤酒厂 De Glazen Toren 呆了大约 90 分钟后——当然我们买了一些瓶装酒带走——我和我的三个朋友出发去拜访西弗勒特伦著名的修士。正如我们前面提到的，如果你想买一箱啤酒，你必须提前订购。不幸的是，萨鲁什运气不好，没订到箱装酒，但他知道至少一到那儿就能品尝一下。
But what I realized as soon as my friends and I got to the Abbey is that Jeff was totally right. The Abbey is in the middle of nowhere. It's surrounded by fields and small houses and it's way out in the western edge of Belgium, very close to the French border. It's totally understandable why the monks decided to institute this new ordering system. If hundreds of cars descended on these tiny roads all of a sudden, it would be disastrous. In other words, designing this whole process to make access difficult to calling the vehicle registration all of it, a lot of it comes down to roads, to infrastructure.
但我和朋友们一到修道院就意识到，杰夫完全是对的。修道院位于荒郊野岭。它被田野和小房子环绕，位于比利时最西端，紧邻法国边境。完全可以理解为什么修士们决定制定这个新的订购系统。如果数百辆汽车突然涌入这些狭窄的道路，将会是一场灾难。换句话说，设计整个流程以使获取变得困难、登记车牌号等等，很大程度上都归结于道路和基础设施。
And there are ways to solve the problem, one is bigger roads, but they could also choose to ship the beer out to the distributor and have no one visit the abbey at all. There are solutions, but it's clearly not a problem the monks want to solve. I did finally get to sit down and have a beer at the cafe across the street, which until this year was the only place that was allowed to resell it, although there's been a thriving blackish grey market for quite some time. I wish I could say that the experience was heavenly. Don't get me wrong, this spear really is fantastic. It's got a complex flavor and is obviously crafted with a lot of care and thoughtfulness. But the flip side of having no label, of having this mythology that brings people from
解决这个问题的方法有很多，一种是修更宽的道路，但他们也可以选择将啤酒运给分销商，让任何人都不用去修道院参观。有解决办法，但这显然不是修士们想解决的问题。我终于有机会坐在街对面的咖啡馆里喝一杯啤酒，直到今年，这里一直是唯一获准转售该啤酒的地方，尽管长期以来一直存在着蓬勃发展的黑灰市。我希望我能说这种体验是天堂般的。别误会我，这款啤酒真的很棒。它有着复杂的风味，显然是用心制作的。但没有标签、这种将
around the world like me to this monastery is that the relationship between customer and brewery feels almost anonymous or generic. It's like my friends and I could have just bought this beer off eBay and enjoyed it almost anywhere, and it would have been basically the same experience, just a lot more expensive. And this is a symptom of the exact same credo that makes the beer rare and exclusive. Clearly, the West Flater and Trappists take pride in creating something great that people enjoy, but you, the consumers of beer, are not the real customer. God is. The head of the Abbey says on their website, we are not roars.
世界各地像我这样的人吸引到这座修道院的神话的另一面是，客户与啤酒厂之间的关系感觉几乎是匿名的或大众化的。就像我和我的朋友们本可以从 eBay 上买到这款啤酒，在任何地方享用它，体验也基本相同，只是贵得多。这是导致这款啤酒稀有且独一无二的同一信条的症状。显然，西弗勒特伦的修士们为创造出人们喜爱的伟大作品而感到自豪，但你们这些啤酒消费者并不是真正的客户。上帝才是。修道院负责人在他们的网站上说，我们不是商人。
We are monks. We brew beer to be able to afford being monks. This beer is not about you and me. They're not creating a purest mystique and challenging us to come to the monastery and experience their beer in a certain way. I am totally ready to capitulate to the monks just like that Connecticut hamburger place. I will do whatever they want me to do. I want them to know that I am on board, that I speak their language, but it turns out they're not even talking to me. As we mentioned earlier, the limited supply of us later in has created a pricey black market.
我们是修士。我们酿造啤酒是为了能够负担得起做修士的开销。这款啤酒与你我无关。他们并不是在创造一种纯粹的神秘感，并挑战我们来到修道院以某种方式体验他们的啤酒。我完全准备好向修士们投降，就像康涅狄格州的那个汉堡店一样。他们要我做什么我都愿意。我想让他们知道我是支持他们的，我懂他们的语言，但事实证明他们根本没在跟我说话。正如我们前面提到的，西弗勒特伦供应有限，催生了一个价格昂贵的黑市。
As I'm recording, I searched for a case of 24 bottles of us later in on eBay, and the current bid is $550 plus $50 shipping to 23 minutes left. The original price paid at the Abbey was just under 50 bucks. To the delight of beer, aficionados worldwide and spring 2012, Vustlatoran beer was finally exported in limited edition packages of four bottles to various countries, including the US. They are called building boxes because the proceeds are slated to go towards the expansion and renovation of the aging Abbey.
在我录音的时候，我在 eBay 上搜索了一箱 24 瓶的西弗勒特伦，当前出价是 550 美元外加 50 美元运费，还剩 23 分钟。在修道院支付的原价不到 50 美元。令全球啤酒爱好者欣喜的是，在 2012 年春季，西弗勒特伦啤酒终于以四瓶装的限量版包装出口到包括美国在内的各个国家。它们被称为建筑盒（building boxes），因为收益将用于资助老化的修道院的扩建和翻新。
And if you're wondering if I did an episode about rare beer and trappest monks partially as an extended metaphor about bizarre customer service, media piracy, and why I can't legally download new episodes of Game of Thrones every Sunday night? Well you wouldn't exactly be wrong. Come on HBO. Even the 17th century monks are sending their beer out in little boxes. On demand. There isn't like a little button I can click and download something.
如果你在想我制作一期关于稀有啤酒和修道院修士的节目，是否部分是作为关于奇特客户服务、媒体盗版以及为什么我不能在每周日晚合法下载新一期《权力的游戏》的隐喻？嗯，你也没完全猜错。拜托，HBO。连 17 世纪的修士都在用小盒子运送他们的啤酒。点播。没有那种我可以点击并下载东西的小按钮。
I want to pay you. Please. A Lannister always pays his debts. 99% Invisible was produced as weep by Sirouce Farovar and me Ronan Mars was special thanks to Sean Seneca. We are a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. Support for 99% Invisible is provided in part by Tiny Letter. Email for people with something to say.
我想付钱给你。拜托。兰尼斯特有债必偿。99% Invisible 是由萨鲁什·法罗瓦尔和我罗曼·马尔斯制作的，特别感谢肖恩·塞内卡（Sean Seneca）。我们是旧金山 KALW 91.7 本地公共广播电台以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。99% Invisible 的部分支持来自 Tiny Letter。为有话要说的人提供的电子邮件。
My boy Carver always said something to say. What do you have to say Carver? Daddy, long ago, I was 22 of 18 eight minutes to fix the look at their nosepilers. They are a reference, but they are not spiders. It's a load off my mind. It's free, easy, minimal, powerful, the simplest way to write any mountainous letter. Online at tinyletter.com. This program is distributed by PR at the public radio exchange making public radio more public online at PRx.org.
我的男孩卡弗（Carver）总是有话要说。卡弗，你有什么要说的？爸爸，很久以前，我是 22 分之 18，还有八分钟来修理……看他们的鼻列。它们是一个参考，但它们不是蜘蛛。这让我卸下了心头大石。它是免费的、简单的、极简的、强大的，是撰写任何长信的最简单方法。在线网址：tinyletter.com。本节目由公共广播交流中心 PRX 发行，使公共广播更加公共，在线网址：PRx.org。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at RomanMarr, but you can always just find the show online and even talk about beer if you want to. I'll just be over here in the corner. I'll just sit on a soda. I'll drive. Don't worry. 99% Invisible.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞该节目。我在 @RomanMarr 发推文，但你随时可以在网上找到该节目，如果愿意的话甚至可以谈论啤酒。我就会待在角落里的这里。我只坐在一罐苏打水上。我来开车。别担心。99% Invisible。
.org If you want to, I'll just be over here in the corner. I'll sit on a soda. I'll drive. Don't worry. 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
.org 如果你愿意的话，我就会待在角落里的这里。我只坐在一罐苏打水上。我来开车。别担心。99%invisible.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。